[Music]  Selena Gomez and the weekend heat things  up on a yacht ahead of Valentine's Day  the couples looking more and more real  check out this pic Selena and the  weekend of full-on making out bow togs  snapped the duo lounging on a boat over  the weekend  I witnessed lzt they spent the night  kissing and snuggling from about 7:00  p.m. until 1:00 in the morning  quote they were very intimate and looked  very much in love can't keep my hands to  myself before the date at sea Selena was  spotted picking out new lingerie at a  boutique in Los Angeles then on Sunday  nights the pair party together after the  weekend rocked the Grammy State